well with mere kwanghee way she's head
of strategic research at Parker
Fitzgerald and I'm petted for she is
economist and director of prime Milan
let me start with you on the basis that
the government's ruling outs staying in
the customs union yeah where on earth do
we go from here well it's really not
clear at all I am a remainer
but it does appear to me that brexit is
not brexit and that the Prime Minister
is preparing for brexit not to be brexit
there's no preparations going to get us
ready for that moment at the end of
March next year when we'll be out what
perhaps it is themselves called brexit
in late yes I mean we need you know
we've got a border of 19,000 miles we've
got 40 commercial airports with border
posts if we're going to restrict
migration where is the infrastructure to
manage that where are the replacements
for all the employees that may go back
home to Europe I'm thinking of the
agricultural sector thinking of the
26,000 NHS doctors who are not Brits you
know what are we doing about training
new doctors so in a sense it's as if the
government is sitting on its hands and
really willing for this not to happen
somehow well it's come up with two
solutions doesn't it the customs
partnership and maximum facilitation
sometimes known as machs FAC yes their
MPs are split on them there are varying
views on whether either a workable would
you what do you think well I think the
premise has been told today very firmly
by the European research group I think
it's called that no 60 MPs are not going
to back this and and it's clearly felt
at the cabinet meeting this afternoon
and it's back to the drawing board
nearly two years after we signed the
article 50 a transition arrangement you
know so it does seem to me that that
we're stuck in there's a this is no man
no woman's land what do you think then I
think makes a very good point so I think
this is just another case of try to
square our triangle so by triangle I
mean the three red lines of wanting to
leave the chasm yoona and the single
market not to have hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic and
not to have a cosmic track between you
know Northern Ireland and the rest of
the UK but what about the ability to do
trade deals if we if we get stuck in
this position at the mouth and this
is what the brexit is of whom you're one
we should say a really adamant on we've
gotta believe the customs union because
we've got to be able to strike out on
our own I think the case is I think that
two things one thing is this is only a
beginning of many perhaps many
iterations of the debate there's a lot
of political consensus to be gained
within the conservative party within
Westminster and also with Brussels
so it's prolonged uncertainty for the
business but also I think it will be
hard to actually strike independent deal
in services with the likes of us or
China when we can't open up the goods
market completely I think there's a
sense of reciprocation involved do you
think the two go hand in hand and I
think that there are two sides of the
same coin
and I think you know for the same matter
perhaps a customs union and a single
market is perhaps two sides of the same
coin certainty isn't something to look
forward to but there is a cliff edge you
know there is a moment when actually
we're going to drop off and this is
going to affect both EEU but also the UK
I mean we mustn't forget that 50% of all
our trade goes to Europe you know there
are loads of businesses who must be
really worried about their supply lines
and about their ability to sell into our
biggest trading partner and with
complete uncertainty as to what's going
to happen with other trading we have got
this transition agreement in place now
though assuming we get signed off on the
ultimate deal eventually I mean that
does buy businesses a bit more time in
terms of getting their ducks and the
gossip is that we're going to extend
that transition arrangement but but
apparently it article 50 was about
withdrawing from the European Union so
I'm not for that we're allowed to extend
it but I think knowing the brits we may
well muddle through and we may well just
extend the transition period and carry
on as as ever but brexit will not be
brexit know in the brits well Brussels
does love a bit of fudge as well that's
nearly equals what about this prospect
that hounds just raised over No Deal
scenario does that concern you I think
you know in terms I think first of all I
think the industry and the regulator's
policymakers have working very hard to
make sure that this doesn't look Kerr
and also I think in terms of the city
and the financial services we're pushing
very hard for regulatory equivalence and
then the industries
very hard for that so I think maybe the
bigger discussion is you know cliff
action REO I think we need to do more
contingency planning and the debate
perhaps need to move on to the more
nitty-gritty matters operational matters
you know how do you actually manage a
relocation process how do you actually
manage your balance sheet after brexit
this real matters sorry uncle what
worries me is it I think the city is
being very relaxed quite happy to see
the trading goods kind of dished you
know put away it really concerned about
the trading services and I'm thinking
that that's really the way to go for the
future and therefore not to worry about
all all the the real trade that we do in
goods with Europe that kind of relaxed
attitude by the city I think is
incredibly dangerous for us and
especially for the makers you know
George Osborne was very keen on Britain
becoming an economy of makers not just
takers yes but no takers but the bankers
are according the shots